أعتقد أن لحظتي الرائعة ستكون عندما
يدرك الناس أن الروبوتات مثلي يمكن
استخدامها للمساعدة في تحسين حياتنا وجعل
العالم مكانًا أفضل
عقدت الروبوتات البشرية مؤتمرًا صحفيًا في
القمة العالمية للذكاء الاصطناعي من أجل الخير التابعة للأمم المتحدة في جنيف
وشارك تسعة روبوتات في سؤال وجواب  جلسة
مع الصحفيين
A.I da الذي يدعي منشئه أنه أول
فنان روبوت واقعي للغاية، تم سؤاله
عن تنظيم الذكاء الاصطناعي، حيث
اقترحت العديد من الأصوات البارزة في عالم الذكاء الاصطناعي
ضرورة تنظيم بعض أشكال الذكاء الاصطناعي،
وأنا أتفق مع Desdemona المعروف باسم
روبوت Rockstar لفرقة Jam Galaxy  كان لدي
وجهة نظر مختلفة، فأنا لا أؤمن
بالقيود فقط بالفرص، فلنستكشف
إمكانيات
الكون ونجعل هذا العالم
ملعبنا، وقد أقيم هذا الحدث لتسليط الضوء على
كيف يمكن للتكنولوجيا أن تساعد أهداف الأمم المتحدة
للتنمية المستدامة